hello and welcome back on root access
Berlin we are again recording here from
the factory studio in Dublin and today I
have with me
Jiro Emoto the CTO of snapengage hello
Jerome hello Buffy can you please
introduce yourself yes absolutely so I'm
Michele Mouton the CTO for that stamp
engage well it's more properly providing
software as a service on the Google
cloud platform or customers are using
cengage to engage their visitors on
their website and to assist them through
the cell cycle or for customer service
so let's see a demo let's see what this
looks like here we have the website of
one of your customers and I have opened
to this little live chat widget that one
is provided by snapengage exactly so
this customers i didn't stamp engage the
transcript client on their website and
when you clicked on the little button to
open the chart this window popped up and
provide you the option to leave a
message part and chat with this customer
and so today we are going to answer a
question there is a recurring question
on aperture how much do these cost every
time I talk about App Engine with
someone that's a question that comes
again because it's not so easy to
determine how much you are going to pay
for your application in App Engine
everything is metered and you pay
according to your bandwidth usage CPU
usage and so on however here with
snapengage we have an application that
has a significant traffic and so
generally is going to tell us about the
associated costs and how to optimize
them it's a first of all zero how much
traffic are we talking about on the
man's an average we serve two billions
of queries in App Engine for that
engaged and we use
you know a fair amount of instances at
tea-time where the dozens of instances
running for serving our credits alright
that's it and so can you tell us what a
typical query landing on your
application looks like so that we
understand what's going on yes so you
were seeing earlier system a window and
to do this this display we have to
figure out or someone in the company it
want to answer the chat in the user
decide to chat
so the typical RPC we do on every
customer web page like this one is to
first bring in the appengine memory
context just the configuration of the
chat team so you know a lot of
configuration details including what is
the agent list for for system what are
the different tiers of agent with a
little booze for for assigning agents
once we have that we need to bring also
in memory what is the status of each
agent of the online post of line how
many chat does effort of their so really
is really handling such we know how to
best to return even right to chat to the
right person so you have first a batch
of requests to the data store sometimes
backed by memcache so as to optimize
them to get the status of your agents
and then you run a CPU intensive
computing algorithm that comes up with
the best agent to answer this query
exactly yeah so let's see how your cost
breakdown looks like you know taking
game it seems that the CPU is is the
most expensive part of your App Engine
cost so what are you doing to to keep
that under control so the first thing
that come in mind of course is to
optimize your code if you want algorithm
inefficient you're going to use more CPU
for that something else you should do if
you your team has the skills on
different languages you should pick a
language it is also efficient at one
time typically
you go with interpreted language I'm
going to take more resources at one time
then if you take a compiled language so
what language are you use well I think
Java which I think your reader knows it
it's a compiled to bytecode so it's not
exactly running on the CPU which
receives the Machine JVM in between but
it's fairly efficient so it's certainly
more efficient than an interpreted
language like Python but you are you
have another option on App Engine which
is go which is completely compliant so
with that probably you would get almost
an order of well almost a factor of 2 of
CPU saving compared to Java but you
haven't tried go we haven't but I think
you should that would be for the most
important services something we should
do let me just interject something here
now with App Engine supporting modules
in theory we should be able to have some
part of the application using the send a
test or stamp in cash but running a
different language that's something were
planning to experimental easy to sell
indeed modules have been introduced
recently and they allow you to split
your application into different modules
but those modules have their own version
their own language however they still
the same application so they hit the
same data store so that that is a good
idea actually to experiment with one
separate functionality written in a
different language and to see what the
impact of that on the CPU cost is some
scans I would like to mention is like
most cloud platforms you can pre
reserved some number of instances that
don't need to use this week so once your
application which level of usage which
is getting you no more than one basic
you can kind of look at what is it is to
read and for the past few weeks
this toy that you know you are going to
use at least that many instances and
tells App Engine dashboard that
to reserve that many instances you don't
have to schedule them overtime just
saying for this week I when used as
administrator
what you gain is instead of paying the I
think eight cents per hour you're going
to pay five cents per hours for the
suite of instances you shouldn't think
we can say okay so it's almost half
prices all right let's go back to the
list so the second most expensive item
here our data store reads again can you
tell us what what you can do with that
yes so reading to data store is
expensive and also is not the fastest
operation you can do so App Engine
provide other platform memcache service
which memcache it's just a key key value
pair in memory on one one system so for
free on the platform you get a shared
memcache service which let you put in
there some cash content that you know
you're going to use quite a bit but it's
a - if Akash so at any point it can tell
you that it has forgotten the content
and you still must have it somewhere in
the datastore that's a throwback but
your your code should be should be
spotting us that if you don't find the
value in memcache you will then get a
datastore but your heat ratio image
cache should be sufficient for you to
say maybe one out of ten or more
requests on the typical difference
between hitting the datastore and
hitting the data store through memcache
is is a reduction of cost of the factor
of ten ten is just number I'm mentioning
here you need to miss significant
certain yeah and so the this shared
memcache has some capacity it can handle
so load and when do you know that you
are exceeding that so yeah it's shared
memcache there's no real numbers that we
can't kind of thing with about 100
megabyte of storage there there is share
the cost
perhaps understand at several what
happened or if some of your liberals
understand observer are using out of
memcache to nucleus of constrained young
man cache lifetime may be reduced so
when you see your cache heat rate and we
used compared to - usually it's most
likely because you're kind of hitting
the limit on the shared memcache so the
shared memcache is free it's normal that
it has some limits what can you do - or
to use water in the cache if that's what
your application limits yes open
application except engage having quite
heavy traffic and we are making good use
of what content ekt in memcache so
instead of having about 100 megabytes of
storage you rent instances of you know
one gigabyte and I think the instance is
rated for up to 10,000 operation per
second ok so that's quite significant a
gigabyte of data and 10,000 operations
per second you can handle a lot of load
with that definitely you can get civil
of this one gigabyte instances if you
need even more and more operation per
second so it's not something typical for
small or startup product and want to do
you see that the expiration of your
content is being pressured and that's
what you can hear to me that because
twice is not expensive what you get it
88 $80 per month for one gigabyte
instances let's get back to this list so
next or data store who writes those who
told me or even more expensive or even
slower so again what can you do it you
to health it there so the one thing you
need to keep in mind is every time you
persist an entity in the dollar store
you're not only processed every
attribute of this quantity every field
but you also ask appengine to create an
index for each of these attendant like
not typically very usual whenever the
person's email address maybe a phone
number processing that will
will not have three right but will have
six right for each indexes as well on
top of that if you need composite
indexes like if you need to be able to
do queries to find people on phone
number or email address not sure what
you would do that you have to define an
additional index in your object
definition that will be also on write
another result right operation so there
is a write amplification effect that
when you write one entity every property
in the entity that is indexed produces
an additional right and also every pair
of properties that is indexed in a
composite index that also produces an
additional right yes so all right so you
have to be very careful with that you
have to be careful in collecting money
and you have a way school you know some
some property and your definition of
object to tell App Engine please do not
create an index for this attribute for
example you know the name of the person
is something you search on so you just
say magazines attribute not indexed and
that's where you can save scene if you
can clean the number of try corporations
but that will prevent you from ever
querying by that property if it's
correct not in there all right but
that's what you are it's a trade-off yes
everybody's like cost versus no atrophy
and so the last item on this list here
is bandwidth so it doesn't seem to be
that significant in your case but you
told me that you optimize those quite
well well what did you do what did you
do to achieve this this Lola similar
things here as well on App Engine for
Java for example you are hosted on the
Sabbath container so you have complete
access to the HTTP headers there are
headers specific for the caching
instruction telling the browser to keep
your content for a certain amount of
time and so by playing with cache
control headers you can you can leverage
a resume addiction of of heat and your
application
telling the browser to reuse what they
have so much
and also well of course that's the
basics but you should be careful of the
the resources that you use images
JavaScript resources and so on the
static resources write something as a
convention here as well not applicable
for everybody but since we are using
Java for our back-end and our team is
very with Java and may also use Java to
create objects trips was a great
framework so by doing that offer the
flexibility for testing debugging but
also rely on the quick compiler to
create highly optimized JavaScript code
for each target so we won't serve the
same JavaScript to a Firefox user
compared to abuser which mean we we
serve the smallest possible amount of
data to each of all of our customers
I think you should all and there is one
more point that I would like you to
touch upon and you told me that you have
started using App Engine before it even
had a name can you tell us a bit more
about that yeah back I think it was very
very soon eight I was caught writing for
Google for some gadget ads project
meaning this very smart ads which show
content context on to what the person's
search where they are located and as
part of doing this contracting had
Authority access to the platform Python
only at the time very limited to all the
functionalities but it allowed me to see
the value of having a system that
skilled in itself as you can imagine
these ad campaigns spark very quickly
when the ad companies lounge and then
scale down quickly as we're going to add
companies turned down so the value
proposition of App Engine to go to scale
and just pay for what you use
it's huge in the situation so that was
back in 2008 or x18 2008 alright so you
are here having an app engine
expert since 2008 yeah and that's
impressive
thank you buddy the thing is when we
decided to launch step and get you
sooner 2009 so one went bigger later we
were already convinced that the platform
was what we wanted to do with a small
team to have the capacity to go quickly
let me mention something else here since
the more time typically when your host
application under the instance based
platform and you have to you know kind
of provision your instances yourself you
we grow by by chunk will you if you see
your perfect is growing they would have
to get an increase of instances of this
traffic scaling down is difficult at
night when the traffic goes down you
typically don't turn off instances
because it's a lot of food product with
App Engine your growth would be linear
because you you pay for what you use the
platform will add instant scenes when
needed when the traffic slows down at
night then we'll take down instances and
you will be charged so it's a huge
difference in the paradigm compared to
traditional hosting all right thank you
very much Cheryl thank you for being
with us here at root access Berlin and
we'll be seeing you in the next episode
of root access Berlin thank you thank
you Martine you me